o gestor 12 para ajeitar as coisas nós
vamos fazer um chá com exposição de
encontros porque já foram mais destacada
a wii e realmente encontrei aqui uma
filosofia que eu acho que mostramos na
[Música]
região e max é estamos a conseguir suja
pessoas
outros não é de 2 duas algumas pessoas
não gosta e não gosta da natureza a
chegar a irmãos e filhos criança chorar
é uma lenda e é o final dava conclui
também que está acontecendo
está é o ganso deu uma pinha de uma
maneira que não os da chuva
o nosso e vamos dar o máximo para ir ao
irã e não sou tão mal mas surgiu essa
distinção
- faço entre o som e anos assassinados e
com um tamanho que é o treinamento
complexo que envolve vários monstros e
volta bem das nossas estradas em
terrenos múltiplas atividades e vão
desde coisas relacionadas com as suas
atividades no dia a dia e errou o fato
nós usávamos a cidade para viver os fora
da cidade
nosso desafio
perdemos chegar e quem também um
comentário comentário quando você ouve
falar dos mapas ruim quanto às vezes
esquecemo-nos de alguns dos tipos de
ruídos que são os nós
nós e nem conhecia o carinho e com
seguranças real e animal considerado
novinha exercício 21 o que não deixa
margem à outra vez
bolatti de maio e as pessoas que estavam
colocadas na arte e na cultura é a
imagem que está são as que existem
técnicas santa supõe um lugar qualquer
coisa
resolvo o problema tecnológico e nesse
caso os mesmos 2014 e está em
funcionamento desde as mais altas nos
deus e portanto
se nós não estamos a ensinar cerro indo
assinar com os seus sons nos lombos
considera ou seja apresentam juros em 12
confrontos da língua zona industrial
conhecem a jogo passo a mãe meus alunos
a fazer nada mas estamos neste ano e em
us 45
a zona é ruim
já adiantando está entre 1 milhão e
algumas ruas é qual é o leão e agulhas
flores será o leão
acho que o outro lado direito e os
baixinhos louca jornadas mistas nua
a música vai para o exterior e senhoras
acho que fui à rua às oito da noite
preta está embaixo faixa nova fase na
cor que eu hein está em cima olhar as
pessoas começam a fazer tudo o que eu
tenho alguma dificuldade em dormir
pior fez o hotel que está a prever
costumo vir uma delas nos contaminar a
outros fomos à vista
é preciso ensinar a ruptura da boa vista
[Música]
qualquer uma destas muito
eu continuo com as novas turmas noturnas
tenho momentos que só em vários tópicos
usina de álcool e à enorme semana cheia
como nos outros estados a rosa dos
ventos que eu está vocês conseguem está
a ver os barcos quase problemas forem
minhas gravatas e
na noite de natal essas pessoas que
sejam gras voz de encarar o local e
fazer inscrições pelo coxa essas sim por
ações também está escolhendo roupas
comuns na hora ou feita em entender o
planeamento podemos atuar vários níveis
quer fazer os usos sejam agora não sei
se passava
está portanto em isso significa que há
uma constituição concentração caixa está
dado está instalado na direita
o sensor é de todos
no gráfico utilizado o ruído social
feito algo que já está em curso é
conhecido então espaço no xix ou outras
cidades e uma já está em curso enquanto
os nossos bichinhos forma então não
existe conhecimento do nosso que é que
algumas ações e no méxico
isto é música i e ii
chama música ou chama sonda tem a ver
com o evento
o sul ou com estes conseguiram arranjar
foram ouvir nesta essa onda gosta do que
está não fica na rua
[Aplausos]